episode 3 of season 4 had a ton of
memorable moments including but not
limited to me Rio using a vending
machine nice high bullying a first-year
high school student and who could forget
these two being super salty about
declan's new internship and we also got
to see Hawks animated for the first time
but we'll get to that bit later so
episode 3 picks off right after the last
one where Deku tried to make certain I
laugh by doing a 10 out of 10 all my
impression and this episode is where we
get the reveal the nod I himself is in
fact a massive weeb now I know he's
Japanese but he can still be a weeb the
reason I say this is because this guy
rips apart deck whose impersonation of
all my because the wrinkles on his face
were like a few centimeters off what the
real almighty looks like seriously bro
we get to see a bunch of his all my
memorabilia including this awesome all
my Funko which I was actually thinking
of getting myself Deku then highlights
how the wrinkles on his face actually
accurate because he was impersonating a
specific incident where all might happen
to look like that and I like this moment
a lot because we get to see some brief
footage of Prime oh my this is the
second time this season that that has
actually happened and long may it
continue
so although Deku couldn't actually make
him laugh they at least got to bond over
their encyclopedic knowledge of the man
himself
so moving on Knight I basically implies
they will take that coupon for an
internship before making the ultimate
dick move Dec who needs this contract
stamped before he can join the agency
and night.i proceeds to go to stamp it
and then stamp the table he then
challenges Deku to stamp the form
himself leading to the main fight of the
episode now just like last week the
visuals here were absolutely top-notch
now we got to see a lot of cool stuff
especially night I effortlessly dodging
midoriya as well as this negative shot
and a few other shots when that ice
quirk you could actually see it at work
but the best thing about this fight to
me was when they revealed their miryo in
his opinion should have been the one to
inherit one for all and if it wasn't for
the episode last week it actually would
have been a really massive reveal but
let's be real here guys myrio does look
like he could be all my son or at the
very least a long-lost cousin or like
half brother or something like that and
his chirpy nature isn't too far removed
from what Prime or might used to be like
but until this season we had never heard
any realistic like concrete evidence
about anyone who could have succeeded or
might other than Deku so you can only
imagine
Deku shocker hearing this but
moving on to the conclusion of the fight
deccan fails to overcome nite ize for
side despite making the pretty smart
deduction that na dies visions don't
actually allow him to see everything in
the future I did kind of like how his
face too slammed into the wall though
like if you look closely you can see the
blood like this bloody nose trailing
down the wall as he comes down as well I
thought that was a pretty cool detail
however despite failing to stand before
deck who does actually managed to make
night air laugh due to the fact that
this whole time he was jumping around my
gran torino he was actually avoiding
touching although all my memorabilia
because he's just that big of a fanboy
and with that done deck who gets his
internship but it should be noted that
the only reason that I actually accepted
wasn't because deck you made him laugh
but rather it was because night I wanted
to show Deku that me Rio is the one who
is worthy of one for all
now the remainder of this episode mainly
consisted of an anime exclusive scene so
this didn't appear in the manga and it's
basically all the students in their
dorms hyping up Deku for getting his
internship and this my friends is where
we finally get to see hawks after four
long seasons although just to set your
expectations
it was literally for three seconds it
was when taki army announced that he was
going to accept an internship there but
I do love how this episode is setting
the foundations already because we know
Hawkes is gonna be in the new movie in
December and now I'm actually pretty
sure he's gonna be at the end of season
4 as well so this is a nice way of
easing him in rather than him just
coming out of nowhere and the funniest
thing about this whole dorm scene was
just total rookie in back ago being like
super jealous of deku surpassing them
and I think for all intents and purposes
these three are obviously being made out
to be the next big three of you eh and
it seems that dec who has done what
Miriah did in terms of just pulling
ahead of the pack but anyway getting
back to the episode there was a
post-credits scene that did actually get
me a little bit hyped just because it
was so menacing so the preview shows a
young girl called
Arry running down a dark alleyway and as
she's running she's being followed by
slow footsteps and a shadowy figure
right behind her now this figure is of
course overall and if you don't know who
that is you can either catch up with my
overhaul explained in two minutes video
or you can watch my episode 2 review
where he kind of like makes his debut
but anyway for me I think this episode
was pretty good though I did think it
ended a bit sooner than I was expecting
I thought we'd go all the way up to
where Arry was interacting with other
people but I guess they're saving that
for episode 4 and to give us that anime
he's seen of the kids in the dorms I
guess it does make sense that they had
to sacrifice something and just push it
back to the next episode but in terms of
saying the groundwork for what's to come
it definitely did that not just by
giving deku his internship but also
adding that scene where taki army
reveals he's going to intern with hawks
and Kirishima and or chaco are both
invited to speak to members of the big
three and for p2 I can't forget floppy
so overall I'll give this episode an 8
out of 10
but what did you guys read the episode
please let me know in the comments and
I'll see you next week peace
you